à cuba sur la place de la révolution
lieu hautement symbolique un demi
million de personnes pour assister à la
messe célébrée par jean paul ii une
homélie politique où les mots de justice
et de liberté sont souvent revenu dans
la bouche du saint-père l'esprit dit il
souffle sur cuba reportage à l'âme
salvan
elle était pleine la plage de la
révolution cinq cent mille personnes et
enthousiastes un enthousiasme
communicatif et fidel castro lui-même au
premier plan semble apprécier le pape
aussi il répond à la foule renversant le
slogan qu'on lui scandent
cuba a mis le paquet avec toi c'est ce
qu'on appelle la manière pontificale se
sont créés les foules et ça marche le
pape ne peut aligner deux phrases de
schwyz sans être interrompu et ils en
redemandent
je ne suis pas contre les
applaudissements quand vous applaudissez
le pape veut un peu se reposer
le discours lui même est un
chef-d'oeuvre équilibre le pape renvoie
dos à dos le système ultralibéral la
toute puissance des marchés qui je cite
provoque un appauvrissement croissant de
tentes pays et le système communiste
avec son athéisme ces atteintes aux
droits de l'homme et à la liberté de
conscience
en recevant mercredi dernier jean paul
ii à l'aéroport de la havane fidel
castro lui avait dit de parler sont
retenus et le pape naturellement ne s'en
est pas privé il a exprimé toutes ces
idées alors certaines vont dans le sens
de castro par exemple la levée de
l'embargo où le discours contre le
libéralisme effréné d'autres en revanche
seuls ici comme des tabous brisés
on ne parlait pas des droits de l'homme
on ne parlait pas de liberté de
conscience on ne parlait pas de
prisonniers politiques et l'accueil
extraordinaire du public vous l'entendez
derrière moi montre bien et devant
castro que c'était le discours que l'on
attendait
à plus bas
et puis entre